destination l'amérique des années 60
[Musique]
c'était pas que vous savez la
ségrégation raciale régner encore temps
de nombreux états si on était noir et si
on voulait voyager dans le pays en
évitant les lieux où on risquait
l'interdiction ou les ennuis
vous pouvez utiliser un nigaud votre
chemise greenbook le guide vert de
l'automobiliste noir ce guide donne son
titre green book de peter farrelly le
film retrace la véritable histoire du
pianiste de jazz denis charlet et de son
chauffeur et garde du corps tommy lipp
lors d'une tournée entre new york et le
sud profond
or dans les deux rôles principaux
marshall à ali oscar du meilleur acteur
pour moonlight vous en souvenez et viggo
mortensen qu'on ne présente plus clair
le pitch greenbook n'est pas sans
rappeler celui de miss daisy et son
chauffeur un film oscarisé en 1990 mais
là la situation est inversée c'est le
blanc qui conduit le noir exactement et
c'est le noir qui est riche
non c'est vrai que mes daisy et son
chauffeur c'était avec morgan freeman
c'était son premier grand rôle
révélation au cinéma qui avait été
oscarisée moi je crois même le parallèle
avec intouchable celle inverse du coup
c'est le personnage riche et noir c'est
ma jalali donc repérer dans moonlight
qui joue donc donne charles est un grand
pianiste afro américains dans les années
60 et viggo mortensen c'est un
italo-américain du bronx très populaire
car sa manière de parler sa manière de
se déplacer et qui est qui en fait c'est
une rencontre c'est un buddy movie c'est
un road movie entre ces deux hommes
paisibles film de potes exactement qui
viennent de deux univers complètement
différent vont-ils apprécier ou non l'un
est un petit peu raciste quand même
viggo mortensen et on voit que voilà pas
à travers à travers l'humour le to va
passer c'est un film qui a remporté
trois golden globes notamment donc
meilleur acteur dans un second rôle pour
my h à la halle et meilleur scénario
meilleur film de comédie est également
et c'est un film qui avait fait un
triomphe au festival de toronto où
j'étais où c'était vraiment salle comble
à chaque séance tanning jeunes parce que
il ya quelque chose du feel good movie
on se sent bien à traverser avec eux ses
paysages et à voir toute cette tension
sociale politique qui a dans les états
unis à cette époque-là revoir des images
claires et bien sûr on va voir des
images de la pensée je vais me taire
pendant cet extra aurès que tout se joue
là c'est on est dans un champ
contrechamp dans un restaurant donc du
point de vue du cochon je n'ai rien à
vous dire mais regarder l'attitude de
l'un et de l'autre et le phrasé de l'un
et de l'autre tout simplement
pas vraiment tenu droite l'autre fume
des clopes en même temps qu'ils mangent
et prend vraiment pour me donnerait
cette réflexion peut être que je peux
être critique culinaire et on voit dans
son humour complètement vulgaire parle
l'échangeur gars qui entre les deux que
le voyage ne va pas être de tout repos
et c'est vraiment c'est vraiment un sim
de d'acteur c'est un film porté par en
fait une marche à la haye et vigo
martens il faut rappeler quand même que
les frères farrelly nous ont habitués
des farces extrêmes parfois potache on
pense tout de suite à fous d'irène à
mary à tout prix la même si le deal
n'est pas dénué d'humour et on le voit
on les un autre registre il est quand
même oui pour cette parce qu'il ya cette
question du racisme et cette question de
l' inversion entre les deux personnages
de classe sociale
mais malgré tout moi ce que j'aime dans
le film c'est que je les retrouve quand
même les farines je les retrouve par
moments ce que est ce que j'aime chez
les farrelly ça veut dire ce cette fois
cette façon à la fois de mêlée quelque
chose d'extrêmement potache de
déjections de 6-4 aux logiques et aussi
de sentimentalité et on retrouve ça dans
ce film j'ai montré un extrait à vous
montrez vous allez voir qu'on les
retrouve on retrouve ça puisque vous
allez avoir cet antagonisme un peu de
personnages burlesques
alors évidemment vous avez les gestes
très délicat de l'un et la façon envoyé
de manger vulgaire de l'autre ils sont
tous les deux ans le plan - cointre et
voyez déjà quelque chose qui se tissent
simplement la façon dont ils sont tous
les deux en train de en train de
déjeuner différemment et là vous allez
voir la science du gag chez les farrelly
chez l'homme marelli retrouvailles et se
trouvant cette nourriture qui est grasse
sur les doigts ses déjections regarder
la bouche de mortensen et hop
au retour tous les deux dans le plan et
vous allez voir
comme toujours chez les farrelly dans la
différence ya une complémentarité et à
sa manière il geste et vous allez voir
troisième acte du gag selon mme coupe
sur la alors ce qui était tout c'est que
chez les farrelly souvent la
sentimentalité elles étaient inclus
graphiquement dans le gars de potash là
le film et plus je dirais assujettis à
un discours et à il ya quelque chose
vraiment sur l'amérique des années 60
moi je trouve c'est un bonheur absolu ce
film j'ai envie de le revoir je trouve
ce film est d'une drôlerie
je trouve les acteurs sont c'est un
bonheur de les regarder pendant pendant
tout le film c'est une histoire qui est
tellement bien raconter je suis je suis
dingue pour la compte et c'est un film
qui a fait beaucoup de polémiques
puisque je rebondis sur l'extrait que
vient de montrer en fait la famille de
jon charlène n'accepte pas cette version
faut savoir que le film a été écrit par
le fils de tony l'ip donc le chauffeur
interprété par viggo mortensen nick veut
la longue à qui lui même a été pris dans
une polémique de tweets au moment du 11
septembre et c'est peter farrelly a
aussi été critiqué pour ses approches un
peu mis tout bref sur des plateaux de
ton approche de mitu qu'il ne devait pas
montrer à ses comédiens etc
mais surtout il ya une grosse polémique
afro américains blancs aux états unis on
sait que c'est toujours très fort sur le
fait que notamment dans cette séquence
on voit comment tony lee apprendre et à
être noir entre l'imea donne charles et
c'est à dire que c'est un noir qui ne
s'est pas manger du poulet
c'est un noir qui ne sait pas comment on
mange du poulet cuit et c'est donc les
polémiques sont partis c'est quand même
peur le politiquement correct je veux
dire parce qu'on voit bien que c'est
quand même très bon esprit enfin je veux
dire à aucun mot alors dont six mots
parce que dans ces cas là il ya quelque
chose qui est quand même très
intéressant dans cette polémique moi que
je trouve excessive et cette polémique à
l'oublier un truc c'est que un
italo-américain dans les années 60 c'est
aussi quelqu'un qui appartient à une
communauté aussi qu'ils étaient
discriminés donc il ya quelque chose de
plus complexe que juste l'opposition
blanc noir ou une simple question de
classe néanmoins moi ce que je note
quand je vois le film aussi chaleureux
et confortable
quel que soit le plaisir géant
y être cette figure ce buddy movie où
deux personnes antagonistes vont un
petit peu racheté les fautes de la
société c'est une figure très forte de
non pas seulement du cinéma mais même de
la culture populaire américaine
et je peux m'empêcher de me dire quand
je vois le film que oui elle est là
aussi un peu vieilli
cette forme cette façon de raconter le
racisme c'est à dire que à force de ne
pas l'envisager comme une question du
collectif et du commun mais uniquement
une question d'individus deux bons
individus peuvent racheter les fautes de
la société et ben non ça en fait pas
moins un film intéressant positif et
plaisant mais dans ce qui veut dire du
racisme en fait il ne dit pas grand
chose m'arrive je rejoins complètement
simon sur le côté politique du film qui
est vraiment inoffensif
il ya une sorte de confort comme tu le
disais alors le film est très plaisant
les acteurs sont merveilleux il ya par
ailleurs et ça je pense que ça tiens
c'est aussi ça doit à l'art de la
comédie
il ya un sens du tempo chez lui il ya un
sens de dire assez brièvement sans en
faire des caisses
comment un type est raciste voilà ils
regardent des verts au début du film
dans lesquels des ouvriers noirs sont
venus boire chez lui et puis voilà un
regard à droite un regard à gauche
personne personne ne surveille ce qui
fait au jet les verts à la poubelle ils
ont été touchées par des afro américains
on pourrait les laver mais on n'est pas
tranquille et que tu es l'image d'après
c'est le bénédicité à table est donc en
moins d'une minute de film
vous connaissez à peu près toute la
personnalité de 2,2 de la personnalité
de départ alors après évidemment il ya
un trajet il ya tout ça est le fils sur
le chauffeur c'est quand même une
traversée oui oui mais rejeté cet
antagonisme sur le fait que les deux ne
peuvent pas logé au même endroit les
deux ne peuvent pas se nourrir au même
endroit des scènes assez violentes de ce
côté là mais c'est vrai que c'est jamais
abordée de manière frontale olivier
clerc à juste titre que le scénario a
été récompensée pourquoi pour quels
traitements pour qu'est ce qui fait la
spécificité de ce scénario parce que je
trouve très bien c'est que justement le
filmer et programmatique mais qu' il
faut qu'ils se hissent octroie des
échappées belles
et effectivement la soirée où ils
peuvent pas aller parce que bachar
assister tout ça c'est pas intéressant
ce qui est intéressant c'est gai du coup
ils vont se faire une soirée à côté dans
un petit bouge où ils vont faire un
boeuf et là tout d'un coup ça devient
intéressant moi le film c'est là où il
me oui me cueille c'est dans les moments
de chaleur entre les deux le côté
message raciste mais tout ça on a déjà
plus à 100 fois ce qui est beau c'est le
côté buddy movie alors il trouve qu'il
ya un contexte du sud des années 60 et
tout ça mais c'est rien de neuf par
contre où le film fonctionne c'est sur
cette complicité là et ces moments là
pour voir green book suivez le guide
jusqu au cinéma le plus proche